Musique contemplative
...
Conversations indistinctes
-Comment distinguer
une grande histoire
d'une simple aventure ?
Faut-il se fier
au premier rendez-vous ?
-J'ai découvert
Jean-Luc Mélenchon
en allant à la mairie.
Il y avait plein de prospectus.
Je me suis dit :
"Ah ouais ?
"C'est qui, ce monsieur ?
On dirait un tonton !"
-Tonton ! On t'aime, tonton !
-Ca me fait marrer. C'est gentil,
je vois bien que c'est gentil.
"Tonton", ça renvoie
à François Mitterrand.
-Une belle rencontre,
est-ce que ça demande pas
de dépasser
sa première impression ?
-J'ai gardé cette image
de Jean-Luc Mélenchon
pendant quelques années,
un vieux fou qui se croit
plus haut que tout le monde.
-Faut-il forcément
admirer l'autre
pour que ça dure ?
-C'est un sacré personnage,
avec du caractère qui parle bien,
qui emporte la foule quand il parle.
-Quel est le secret
de la réussite d'une relation
entre un homme politique
et ses soutiens ?
Qui sont ces 30 %
de jeunes Français
qui ont voté
pour Jean-Luc Mélenchon ?
-Je vous souhaite la majorité.
-Comment le fondateur
de la France Insoumise est-il devenu
le rival de l'abstention
chez la nouvelle génération ?
Pourquoi Yann, Juliette, Dalia
et tant d'autres citoyens
et citoyennes de moins de 30 ans
ont décidé de faire confiance
au plus âgé des candidats,
trois fois perdant
à la présidentielle ?
-Ce qui m'a poussé
à voter pour lui,
déjà, c'était le programme
environnemental.
-Si on veut vivre bien,
il faut faire des réformes
dans la police.
-Les violences sexistes
et sexuelles :
1 milliard pour lutter
contre la violence patriarcale.
-On a quelqu'un qui,
même s'il n'est plus tout jeune,
pas jeune du tout, est quand même
à l'écoute de ce qu'il se passe.
C'est important.
C'est la jeunesse
qui va subir l'avenir du pays.
Je dis bien "subir".
*-Tu te sens écoutée,
mais tu te sens écoutée
par un ancien.
C'est assez rare, mine de rien.
-Les jeunes
et Jean-Luc Mélenchon :
sur quoi repose cette union ?
-Ca provoque de la colère.
-Je suis en colère.
-Ca me met en colère.
-Il y a quelque chose
dans la "colère" insoumise
qui relève
de l'indignation, de dire :
"Mais vous êtes fous, quoi !"
-La personnalité
de Mélenchon est-elle
compatible avec le projet
de ses neveux et nièces ?
-On doit changer le système.
-Jean-Luc comprend-t-il
vraiment les préoccupations
de la jeunesse insoumise ?
-J'ai pas pensé : "Les jeunes
vont m'apprendre ça ou ça".
-Ou sa capacité de mise à jour
a-t-elle atteint ses limites ?
-Bonsoir.
-Je ne dois pas réviser
ma position à cause de vous.
-Pourquoi pas ?
-Ben non ! Non ! Non !
Non, non. J'ai plus envie.
-Jean-Luc Mélenchon
va-t-il laisser sa place ?
Pourquoi passer le flambeau
paraît-il si compliqué ?
-Il a vraiment construit
la génération qui vient après.
*-Les plus jeunes vont me dire :
"Eh ben !
On n'y est encore pas arrivés !"
Musique à suspense
C'est pas loin, hein !
...
"Faites mieux, merci".
Musique intrigante
...
-Pour commencer,
il faut poser les bases.
Une bonne relation, c'est avant tout
une bonne communication.
-Hello ! Comment ça va ?
-Sauf qu'en politique,
c'est pas tout à fait
comme dans la vraie vie.
On a la chance de pouvoir
faire appel à des professionnels.
-Je suis Antoine Léaument,
j'ai 33 ans
et je suis député de l'Essonne
pour la France Insoumise.
J'ai été responsable
de la communication numérique
de Jean-Luc Mélenchon.
Je m'occupais
de ses réseaux sociaux, globalement.
Je pense que ce serait pas mal
de faire des plans de ce sens-là :
là-bas, t'as des bâtiments
qui montrent qu'on est
dans un quartier pop. Sinon,
on dirait qu'on est à la campagne.
-Pendant 10 ans,
Antoine a oeuvré
pour que son patron
soit plus qu'un homme politique.
Léaument a les codes des réseaux,
Mélenchon, le talent oratoire.
Ensemble,
ils créent "Jean-Luc l'influenceur".
-J'ai commencé en 2013.
Il avait quelque chose
comme 200 000 abonnés
sur son compte Twitter
et 100 000 sur sa page Facebook.
Aujourd'hui,
on est à 2 millions sur Twitter
et 1 million sur Facebook.
-Ma ligne générale,
c'est :
tous les médias m'intéressent,
sans exception,
quel que soit le lieu, le format.
-Il y a plein de jeunes
qui sont passés
pour vérifier que c'était bien ici,
donc je suis plutôt confiant.
-J'ai connu la période
où on faisait des tracts,
on se mettait de l'encre
jusque dans le nez.
Et quand on avait fait
5000 tracts,
on pensait qu'on était
les maîtres du monde.
Bon, si j'avais su à l'époque
que je ferai en une semaine
11 millions de vues sur TikTok,
je sais pas, peut-être
que je me serais évanoui.
-On a l'impression
qu'il va y avoir personne.
On est l'homme politique
numéro 1 sur les réseaux sociaux
en considérant que c'est pas
des outils de communication,
mais d'information
qui permettent de faire
passer des idées
et de construire
dans la durée.
-C'est le contournement
de la sphère officielle.
Donc nous qui sommes pointus, aigus,
qui avons calibré un message,
on va pouvoir passer
à travers ça.
Ca marche pas à chaque fois.
-Qu'est-ce qu'on impose
dans l'agenda médiatique ?
-Oui,
l'agenda médiatique des gens
qui nous intéressent !
-Avec Antoine,
Jean-Luc a trouvé
un de ses meilleurs
entremetteurs politiques.
Qui de mieux qu'un ancien centriste
pour convaincre les citoyens
de se laisser séduire
par la gauche ?
-J'étais plutôt de droite.
J'étais plutôt côté Bayrou.
Si j'avais pu voter en 2007,
j'aurais voté Bayrou
au premier tour,
et Sarkozy au deuxième.
J'étais vraiment
bien parti à droite.
C'est vraiment le moment où,
c'est le hasard,
j'ai découvert Mélenchon,
avec un bouquin,
"Qu'ils s'en aillent tous".
Je l'ai trouvé génial.
J'étais d'accord
avec lui de A à Z.
-Le V.
-Le V !
Ils rient.
-Parce qu'en fait,
on a fait un snap
avec un rappeur local, et j'ai dit :
"Il faut voter pour le V".
Maintenant, je suis devenu le V.
Ils m'appellent le V, les jeunes.
Si on a beaucoup investi
les réseaux sociaux,
c'est parce qu'on s'est dit
que les jeunes votaient peu
et qu'il fallait les convaincre
d'aller voter.
Là, chez les jeunes,
on a fait des scores vraiment
hyper impressionnants,
et particulièrement chez les jeunes
dans les quartiers populaires.
Ce qu'on essaye de faire,
c'est de les convaincre
de nos idées politiques
et du fait
que c'est les idées de l'avenir.
-Un projet d'avenir,
pas une histoire
d'un sort d'élection.
-Il y a l'aspect électoral,
bien sûr, un aspect d'urgence :
"Il faut qu'on gagne",
mais il y a aussi
le plus long terme,
une bataille culturelle.
-Construire une relation
durable avec les citoyens,
les convaincre
d'adhérer à un projet
de rupture, ça demande
d'y croire à fond,
quitte à paraître un peu fan.
*-Merci d'être venu si nombreux.
Je suis Antoine Léaument,
le candidat dans la 10e
circonscription de l'Essonne,
aussi connu
sous le nom de monsieur V.
Je vous dis juste une chose.
On a la possibilité de tout changer.
On peut faire
le SMIC à 1500 euros,
le blocage des prix,
la retraite à 60 ans,
supprimer Parcoursup.
Je sais que c'est un problème ici.
Nous aurons celui que vous attendez
pour prendre la parole
comme Premier ministre,
Jean-Luc Mélenchon !
C'est plus qu'un patron pour moi.
Ca a été d'abord un mentor.
*-J'ai coupé la parole...
au presque meilleur des nôtres.
On prend tous les bulletins
pour que personne
sache ce qu'on va faire,
Ensuite, on rentre dans le machin,
on tire le rideau,
on choisit le bulletin.
Le meilleur,
c'est celui où on voit le...
-V !
-Faites voir avec les mains ?
Votez Victoire !
Musique solennelle
En France,
les personnes plus âgées
vont plus voter que les autres.
Et il arrive
que quand l'âge vient,
on devient plus craintif,
plus conservateur.
Et on n'aime pas
trop que tout change,
tout bouge tout le temps.
On trouve que les jeunes
sont bien agités,
et qu'ils devraient
être un peu plus calmes.
-Mélenchon, l'homme qui a trouvé
le secret de la jeunesse éternelle :
une histoire vraie
ou juste
une story de plus ?
Le profil des élus vise à toucher
les citoyens au coeur :
âge, origines
géographiques et sociales,
valeurs, façon d'être...
Les points communs
et les différences
sont scrutés, jugés.
En politique, l'algorithme
peut donner des matchs improbables,
comme un homme de 71 ans
avec des djeuns,
ou un Antoine Léaument
dans les quartiers populaires.
-J'ai pas grandi
dans un quartier populaire,
et j'ai pas grandi dans une ville
de la périphérie de Paris.
J'ai grandi
dans une petite ville de province,
comme on dit : Châteauroux.
OK, je suis blanc.
C'est ça, la question.
Les problèmes que j'ai rencontrés
sont liés à la ruralité.
C'est des problèmes similaires
aux quartiers populaires,
moins le racisme.
-Selon vous, il n'y a pas
de moyens de faire en sorte
que la jeunesse
qui vit en banlieue ait plus envie
de s'investir en politique et de...
-Non, non.
Ils doivent faire le boulot.
Rien n'est jamais cadeau,
les jeunes.
Ca existe pas.
Surtout si t'es pauvre,
si tu viens de milieu populaire.
La seule consigne, c'est bats-toi.
-"Rien n'est jamais cadeau",
mais certaines mesures politiques
peuvent aider à faire sa place
et donc s'engager.
Si chacun est responsable
de son destin,
l'environnement social
joue aussi un grand rôle.
Pour rappel,
la lutte contre Parcoursup
et son système scolaire élitiste
figure au programme
de la France Insoumise
En quoi Mélenchon
serait-il le mieux placé
pour représenter
la jeunesse de banlieue ?
Une jeunesse connectée, certes...
-Il n'y a pas
de belles photos de l'accolade
avec Jean-Luc ?
-Il y a la petite vidéo
avec Pierre.
-Bon, bah c'est pas de chance.
-...mais une jeunesse
qui attend surtout l'étape d'après,
trouver enfin cette personne
qui comprend leurs besoins,
une personne qui incarne
le progrès social.
-Parfois, je me dis
que la journée est finie,
mais non, elle est pas finie.
-Comment ça se passe,
la première fois
qu'on se motive
pour aller voter
et qu'il faut donner sa confiance
à un inconnu ?
Est-ce qu'on se lance
tête baissée, les yeux fermés,
ou plutôt avec prudence ?
-J'ai voté utile.
Jean-Luc Mélenchon,
c'est pas le choix parfait,
c'est juste un bon début
pour atteindre des objectifs.
Je m'appelle Dalia. J'ai 25 ans.
J'ai toujours grandi
et vécu en banlieue.
J'ai une licence en japonais.
Je travaille en échoppe asiatique.
-Le système de vote en lui-même
déjà est biaisé...
*-Mesdames messieurs,
il y a des incidents de normes
mais la circulation continue.
Vous pouvez aller
sur le quai juste en face.
Dalia râle.
-Si Dalia et sa soeur Yasmine
ont décidé
de soutenir Jean-Luc Mélenchon,
c'est avant toute une question
de foi et de traumas.
-J'ai grandi dans une ville...
J'avais des amis au collège
qui arrivaient un jour
à l'école,
et ils avaient des bleus :
ils avaient fait une garde à vue.
Leur seule erreur,
c'était d'être partis
faire les courses
sans leur justificatif d'identité.
En banlieue,
on est conditionnés à penser à ça,
et si on ne le fait pas,
on sait qu'on risque
d'avoir des problèmes.
-Sarcelles, au nord de Paris.
Comme dans beaucoup
d'autres banlieues,
la moitié des votants a glissé
un bulletin Mélenchon dans l'urne
à la dernière présidentielle.
Promesse de réformer la police,
soutien à la communauté musulmane...
Jean-Luc a rallumé un espoir.
-Je vais aller prier, habibi.
-Vas-y, ça marche.
Tu veux que je coupe
des légumes en attendant ?
-Je veux bien,
s'il te plaît.
La prière, c'est quelque chose
qui a une place importante,
sauf que de base,
je dois prier à des moments précis,
mais pour des raisons de laïcité,
je ne prie pas
sur mon lieu de travail,
donc les jours où je travaille,
je rate mes prières.
En rentrant, je les rattrape.
C'est un moment où je sais
que personne ne va me déranger.
C'est mon moment à moi.
Ca me prend quelques minutes
dans la journée,
et c'est quelques minutes
de pur silence autour de moi.
Musique apaisante
...
-Je comprends de quoi
il s'agit.
J'ai moi-même été un jeune croyant.
Puis les circonstances
de l'existence
m'ont éloigné du discours
et de la pratique
de la foi catholique.
Je suis pas surpris
qu'un jeune soit croyant.
Ca me semble pas
une monstruosité.
-De temps en temps,
comme ça, dans ma vie,
je suis choquée
par ce qui m'entoure.
Je peux rencontrer quelqu'un,
être amie avec cette personne
pendant des années, et d'un coup,
cette personne me dit
une monstruosité raciste.
On me dit qu'on me déteste moi
et ceux qui me ressemblent.
Enfin non,
on me déteste pas moi,
parce que "je suis pas
comme les autres", justement.
Ben si, en fait.
Moi aussi, je suis comme ça.
Je suis exactement comme les autres,
ceux que tu détestes :
les Arabes et les musulmans.
Ben devine quoi ?
Mauvaise nouvelle.
J'en suis une.
-La patrie républicaine,
elle est à tous ses enfants.
Cette jeune femme,
c'est ma compatriote.
Je ressens une profonde
idée d'attachement
et je ne supporte pas ceux
qui voudraient provoquer,
dans ce pays,
cette coupure abominable.
La voie de passage,
c'est pas essayer d'extirper
la religion du coeur des gens.
Ca ne sert à rien.
-C'est un truc
qui a changé,
depuis que tu t'es remise
à prier, tout doucement :
c'est que je te sens
beaucoup plus sereine.
-C'est le cas.
C'est... C'est le cas.
Je suis beaucoup plus sereine.
J'ai l'impression d'avoir
moins de pression sur les épaules.
-Un discours de tolérance
vis-à-vis des religions étonnant.
Connu et reconnu
pour ses positions
anti-communautaristes,
Jean-Luc Mélenchon
renie-t-il son passé ?
-Il y a 30 ans,
j'aurais pas réagi comme ça.
Tout m'insupportait :
les bonnes soeurs en cornette...
-Que s'est-il passé ?
-Après,
vous recevez la leçon
de la vie.
Vous dites : "Ca n'a pas de sens,
d'être comme ça."
Par ce que, si vous êtes
un anticlérical forcené,
qui ne supporte
aucune pratique religieuse,
ça élimine bon nombre de gens
autour de vous.
-Opportunisme électoral ?
Antiracisme sincère ?
Jean-Luc Mélenchon
met sa capacité
de remise en question
au service
de la lutte contre un ennemi
que lui et Dalia ont en commun.
-J'ai grandi à Garges,
dans le 95,
je voulais faire mon devoir
de citoyenne, d'une manière
ou d'une autre, donc je me suis
proposée pour dépouiller.
Garges est une ville...
un melting-pot,
en fait : il y a toutes les cultures
qui sont mélangées.
Dans les rues,
à Garges,
on n'a pas l'impression
que le racisme existe.
Après, on se retrouve,
on ouvre le premier vote,
et : Marine Le Pen !
Et on se dit : "Ah !
"Ils sont où, ces gens,
dans la vraie vie, exactement ?
"Ils sont où,
en fait ?"
Je me suis dit :
"Mais dans quel monde je vis,
finalement ?"
On se dit : "Qu'est-ce qui va
se passer, pendant ces élections ?
Je suis franco-égyptienne.
J'ai pas envie de vivre
dans un pays qui me déteste.
Parce que j'ai envie
d'avoir des enfants, un jour.
J'ai pas envie de leur donner
un pays qui les déteste.
-Combattre l'extrême droite
par tous les moyens,
lutter contre le racisme quotidien,
pas c'est aussi partir en guerre
contre un adversaire
bien plus difficile
à neutraliser.
-Il manque un peu de sel.
C'est faux de dire
qu'il n'y a pas de racisme d'Etat :
dans ce pays,
quel que soit
notre statut social, quand on n'est
pas blanc, on aura des difficultés.
-Quand on ressent ce privilège
d'être un homme blanc ?
-On réalise pas,
il faut qu'on vous le dise.
Au début, j'ai dit :
"Ca va pas ?
"C'est quoi, le privilège
d'un homme blanc pauvre ?"
On m'a dit :
"On va te raconter."
Quand on vous le raconte,
vous vous dites
que c'est pas que faux.
Parce que ça touche à tout,
à l'intime.
-Vous vous définiriez comment ?
-Etre humain.
Je ne suis d'aucune communauté
fondée sur la couleur de peau.
Quelle horreur !
-Qui peut affirmer, aujourd'hui,
ne pas se définir
par sa couleur de peau ?
Pour qui l'intime
n'est-il toujours pas politique ?
Pour ceux qui peinent
à prendre conscience
de leurs privilèges.
-C'est réconfortant,
comme plat.
Jean-Luc Mélenchon n'incarne pas
l'antiracisme tel qu'on aimerait
le voir, en France,
mais c'est
un bon début.
Si je devais faire des choix
par rapport à l'antiracisme,
en France, politiquement,
je voterais pas Jean-Luc Mélenchon.
C'était bien
plus présent
dans le discours Poutou
que celui de Mélenchon.
Mais, encore,
il s'agirait d'unir la gauche.
-C'est trop bon.
-On passe un bon moment.
-Je t'aime.
-Moi aussi, je t'aime.
-Je sais pas si je t'aimerais autant
si tu savais pas cuisiner.
Elle rit.
Ah, désolée.
La vérité est sortie.
Musique éthérée
...
-La passion du début.
A la découverte de l'autre
et de son univers.
Les yeux, le coeur :
tout est grand ouvert.
-1re fois que je le vois
porter du maquillage, et je le fais.
Il est beau,
mon coeur !
-Ils est beau, ton coeur.
-Oui, il est beau.
-On se laisse prendre
par la main,
jusqu'à Annecy,
pour la marche des Fiertés,
en soutien
à la communauté LGBTQIA+,
Et pas avec n'importe qui :
avec toute la famille.
-On parle assez peu politique,
dans ma famille,
et, en arrivant à paris,
j'ai rencontré
des personnes
qui m'ont politisé.
-Tu en as combien, là ?
-Plein.
J'ai mal au bras.
Je m'appelle Yann Guérin.
J'ai 24 ans, depuis cet été.
Fraîchement diplômé
des Arts et Métiers,
une école d'ingénieurs.
Je suis ingénieur en CDI.
-La vie parisienne,
la politique, Mélenchon :
Yann a tout découvert
en même temps.
-En 2017,
j'étais pas politisé.
J'avais eu un papier
dans ma boîte aux lettres,
d'Emmanuel Macron,
qui avait dit :
"Le candidat des jeunes",
"C'est notre projet" et tout.
Et, du coup,
j'ai voté Emmanuel Macron !
Il rit.
J'assume plus, maintenant !
Mais c'est une erreur de parcours,
une erreur de jeunesse.
-Une erreur
que peu reconnaissent.
Le vote gay pour Mélenchon
ne va pas toujours de soi.
Macron, Le Pen
et même Zemmour
sont aussi appelés dans les urnes
par la communauté.
Même si Mélenchon reste un des rares
à penser à elle
dans son programme.
-J-L. Mélenchon,
j'aime sa capacité
à accepter
de changer d'avis,
l'humilité qu'il a
de dire :
"J'ai eu tort. A cette époque-là,
j'avais dit quelque chose,
"mais j'ai eu tort, car j'ai eu
de nouvelles informations depuis,
"et avec ces nouvelles informations,
j'ai changé d'avis,
"et maintenant,
mon avis, c'est ça."
Exemple : sur les personnes
transgenres, il me semble,
-Je pars de rien du tout,
à dire :
"C'est quoi, cette histoire ?
C'est un non-sujet."
puis, je participe
à la moyenne,
un peu narquois :
"Vraiment, c'est un sujet ?
"Quoi, tu sais pas si tu es un homme
ou une femme ?"
Le truc niveau zéro, quoi.
Hein.
Vous êtes interpellé
par des jeunes camarades,
vous avez de l'estime pour eux, et
on vous amène un problème comme ça.
"Bon... On va réfléchir."
Et puis,
il y a les expériences.
Je rencontre
une personne transgenre.
Tout d'un coup, le regard change,
sur plein de choses.
-Faire de la place à toutes
les identités, faire la Gay Pride
avec sa mère, c'est aussi ça,
la génération Mélenchon.
-"Iel", ceux qui sont
ni "il", ni "elle".
-Les non-binaires ?
-Oui.
Sur moi, je peux être une "iel".
-Non, "iel", c'est le pronom.
"I-e-l", le pronom "iel".
-Ah.
-Une génération
qui réinvente le présent
et imagine un futur vivable.
-On est là pour pécho.
Oui, le but est de pécho.
Ben oui.
Enfin, moi !
Toi, tu fais ce que tu veux.
Regarde : "Free kiss",
faut faire des bisous.
*Musique festive
-Peut-être car cette génération,
comme Mélenchon, apprend du passé.
-J'ai pas envie
de revoir les gens
qui m'ont harcelé au collège
et de faire comme si on était potes.
-Tu as été harcelé ?
-Ah oui.
-Au début des années 1990,
Jean-Luc est sénateur
et propose,
dans la foulée,
la première loi pour créer
un partenariat civil,
le fameux PACS.
-J'avais un peu
un remords, parce que, en 1982,
quand François Mitterrand
et ses gouvernements
ont aboli la punition
- c'était criminalisé,
l'homosexualité - ,
j'ai fait partie, je pense,
j'ai pas de souvenirs précis,
des gens qui disaient :
"Franchement,
"on n'a pas plus urgent ?"
C'était la mentalité.
C'était : "On n'a pas dit
qu'on allait faire le socialisme ?
"Alors, il est où ?"
C'est le côté
un peu rustre.
En tout cas, je n'ai pas compris,
à l'époque, de quoi on parlait.
Ca m'intéressait pas.
Quand ces gens arrivent...
"Oh !"
Tout d'un coup, je découvre ce monde
de cruautés, de brutalités,
qu'on avait tous
sous les yeux.
-Oui, il y a eu
des pensées très sombres.
J'ai voulu faire des trucs
qu'il faut pas faire.
Il y a eu
un moment où,
vraiment,
ça allait pas du tout,
et où je me faisais harceler,
beaucoup, beaucoup.
C'était en quatrième,
si je dis pas de bêtises.
J'ai eu des pensées suicidaires,
quand même, à l'époque.
J'ai eu des moments
où j'étais...
pas loin du tout.
Et, heureusement
que j'ai rien fait.
Enfin...
Et heureusement
que j'ai rien fait.
Mais... mais l'idée
était là, quoi.
Musique électro éthérée
...
Oh, il a une énorme bite.
-C'est incroyable.
-J'aime beaucoup.
Il me faut la même chose.
Pour mon anniversaire,
je veux une grosse bite.
"Nous sommes féministes
et en colère", OK, j'ai.
J'ai les paroles.
"Nous sommes queers !
Nous sommes fiers.
Il faut chanter les chants
un peu... d'extrême gauche, là !
Allez !
Les islamo-gauchistes,
on chante ensemble !
-Racisme, discrimination de genre,
justice écologique et sociale :
Jean-Luc a su capter les intérêts
d'une jeunesse progressiste.
-Nickel.
-Venu du monde d'avant,
Mélenchon parviendra-t-il
à tenir le rythme
de ces nouveaux partenaires ?
Cette jeunesse n'attend pas
qu'on lui donne la permission
Pour embrasser le nouveau monde
et ses combats.
-D'être moi à 100 %
et de le montrer autant,
c'est une revanche
sur toutes les personnes
qui m'ont dit
que c'était pas normal d'être moi.
Mon orientation sexuelle
fait de moi une minorité.
Même si je suis
un homme blanc cisgenre,
je reste une minorité.
Ca m'a permis aussi de m'ouvrir
aux personnes discriminées
et, du coup, politiquement,
ça me fait aller vers des partis
qui vont aider ces personnes.
Musique éthérée
...
-L'entrée à la fac.
On change de vie, on se fait
de nouveaux amis.
C'est comme se choisir
une nouvelle famille,
une famille réunie autour de valeurs
et de causes communes.
-C'est au meeting de Mélenchon
dans lequel
il présente ce que sera
l'Union Populaire que j'ai rencontré
les gens qui sont aujourd'hui
mes plus proches amis.
Du coup, c'est à partir
de ce meeting-là
que je me suis
vraiment engagée,
que j'ai pas arrêté
par la suite, quoi.
Je m'appelle
Juliette Malbois,
j'ai 20 ans.
Je suis étudiante
en information-communication,
à Rennes 2
et je milite aussi,
à côté de mes études.
-Venez, venez, venez !
Alors...
Première chose : merci beaucoup
d'être venus nous aider.
-Après la présidentielle,
la campagne législative,
je m'étais dit
que je ne pouvais pas
ne plus rien faire.
Du coup, j'ai décidé
de m'engager
dans un syndicat étudiant,
pour lutter
contre la précarité.
-Juliette découvre
Jean-Luc Mélenchon
en 2017.
Elle a 16 ans
et voit son frère militer
pour la présidentielle.
Trois ans plus tard,
elle commence des études
à Rennes,
et s'engage
auprès des jeunes insoumis,
loin de son milieu d'origine.
-Je suis née à Angers.
J'ai grandi
dans une petite commune
du Maine-et-Loire, dans le 49,
à Saint-Martin-d'Arcé,
et mes parents
sont cadres.
Je suis de la petite bourgeoisie
des campagnes !
-On en revient
à la distribution.
Vous avez vu qu'on a réparti
les produits par table,
selon les types de produits :
les féculents, l'épicerie salée,
l'épicerie sucrée,
les fruits et les légumes.
Le rôle des gens,
une fois tout installé,
est, aux tables
- désolé, c'est pas
un travail amusant -, de vérifier
que les gens ne prennent
pas plus que prévu.
Sur les épiceries salées et sucrées,
c'est deux produits.
Il va falloir répéter, beaucoup.
Quand les gens arrivent,
vous leur redites, et, surtout
- il y a du bruit ambiant -,
il faut le faire avec les doigts.
Dites : "Deux produits."
-La moitié
de la jeunesse étudiante !
Sur 2 millions,
ça fait 1 million,
travaille pour suivre ses études.
Quand, moi, j'étais étudiant...
Je sais pas,
on devait être...
Rien, 10 % !
Qui travaillaient un peu le soir,
un peu ci, un peu là...
Maintenant, c'est la moitié !
C'est une jeunesse qui a
les deux caractéristiques :
impliquée, comme on dit,
dans la vie "matérielle",
"concrète",
et dans l'état
de disponibilité intellectuelle,
pour regarder le monde.
Donc, oui,
on peut apprendre beaucoup.
-La précarité étudiante,
on a commencé vraiment à en parler
pendant le Covid,
mais, depuis, ça s'est pas arrêté.
Cette année,
c'est entre 500 et 600 étudiants
à chaque distribution.
L'Union Pirate,
c'est un syndicat étudiant,
à Rennes,
qui est majoritaire.
Avec l'Union Pirate
on essaye de...
de faire en sorte
que ça se déroule au mieux,
pour pas que ce soit trop
une...
un moment chiant, parce que
c'est pas toujours agréable, déjà,
d'aller aux distributions.
Ca prend du temps
sur les cours aussi,
c'est pas toujours agréable
de montrer aux autres
qu'on est dans une situation
de précarité,
qui nous oblige à devoir faire
30 min de queue
pour récupérer un sac.
-Tu as droit à deux articles
sur l'ensemble de la table.
Je sais pas si tu as déjà pris
deux articles ?
Tu veux reposer ça ?
Tiens.
Prends... Oh, pardon.
Le dégoût. J'ai beaucoup de colère
envers le gouvernement,
qui se rend pas compte
de cette détresse-là,
de la jeunesse
et des étudiants.
-Comme Juliette, de plus en plus
de jeunes privilégiés
se reconnaissent
dans le mouvement
de la France Insoumise.
Un non-sens ?
Pas tant que ça,
quand on connaît la situation
de Jean-Luc Mélenchon.
Issu d'un milieu modeste,
le populiste déclare
un patrimoine d'un peu plus
d'un million d'euros.
-Bourgeois ou pas, vous voyez bien
que ça ne peut pas durer comme ça :
on saccage la planète !
Même bourgeois,
vous avez une conscience !
Mais la conscience sociale,
c'est ce qui retarde le plus
chez le bourgeois.
Il faut donc amener...
Je dis "le bourgeois"
pour caricaturer.
Mais tout le monde peut
être convaincu. J'en rêve.
Notamment dans mon idée
de la révolution citoyenne.
-Je me bats pas pour moi. Quand
je demande une meilleure répartition
des richesses.
C'est pas pour mes parents,
car ils s'en sortent
globalement très bien.
C'est... une question
d'égalité : j'ai envie
que tout le monde soit...
Puisse vivre
dans les mêmes conditions,
et que personne ne s'inquiète
de comment finir le mois
ou de nourrir ses enfants.
-En fait, tu rencontres
ceux pour qui
et ce pour quoi tu te bats.
Tu connaissais l'Union Pirate,
avant ?
-De nom, oui.
Ca fait un an que je suis à la fac.
-OK, trop bien.
Du coup, les distrib alimentaires,
tu trouves ça...
En termes de quantité,
ça te suffit ?
-Oui.
J'ai pas les moyens
parce que je vis qu'avec la bourse.
L'année dernière,
je n'avais pas entendu parler
de tout ça.
Du coup, je vivais qu'en mangeant
des pâtes.
-L'avenir de la France,
l'avenir des insoumis,
c'est en partie ici qu'il se joue.
-Ca fait plaisir.
-Ca te permet de manger plus varié
et peut-être plus équilibré aussi,
même si ça, c'est pas forcément..
-Oui, mais j'ai pris...
-Oui, il y a des fruits et légumes.
-J'essaie de diversifier.
-Ouais, c'est cool, OK.
-Entre les boîtes de conserve
et les stickers de l'Union Pirate,
on aide ceux qui en ont besoin,
on réseaute,
on fait de la politique.
-Avoir un taf en parallèle
de ses études, c'est la première
cause de l'échec des études.
C'est un cercle vicieux :
t'es en difficulté économiquement,
pour payer tes études,
tu travailles, et tu mets en danger
tes études.
C'est ce que la macronie appelle
la méritocratie,
ce qui n'existe pas.
Du coup, c'est un peu,
indirectement...
verser un discours de gauche
dans les esprits.
C'est la solidarité, on organise ça
parce que le gouvernement
fait rien à côté.
Je pense que c'est aussi transmettre
des discours de gauche
qui sont indispensables.
Qui sont indispensables.
Musique douce
...
Musique intrigante
-Le moment où on s'installe :
on est dans le vrai, le concret,
la tête dans le chantier.
-Du coup, là, en fait,
on met des cales
pour pouvoir avoir
un plancher pour mettre ensuite
la cuve souple qui nous permettra
de stocker le plateau.
-En 2017, il y a
les élections présidentielles.
J'étais beaucoup sur les réseaux,
à commenter, machin,
derrière mon ordi, à lire,
à répondre aux commentaires.
J'étais pas un troll,
j'aime pas ce mot.
Je te faisais des pavés
avec tout l'argumentaire.
Parfois, ça marchait.
Je m'appelle
Simon Braquemart, j'ai 31 ans,
et je suis régisseur
sur des tournages de fiction.
Je suis néo-rural,
j'aime bien dire ça,
parce que je suis citadin
dans l'âme, mais j'habite
à la campagne.
-Il y a 12 ans,
j'imaginais pas du tout habiter
dans un hameau, avec Simon,
et faire des projets potagers
et compagnie.
-Marianne et Simon
sont intermittents
du spectacle. Après des années
à Paris et Bruxelles,
ces deux militants
de la France Insoumise sont partis
vivre au fin fond de l'Alsace,
à Sainte-Marie-aux-Mines,
dans le Haut-Rhin.
-C'est du travail, oui, de s'occuper
d'une maison,
de devenir autonomes, etc.
La maison, c'est beaucoup
de travaux manuels.
Je suis pas bricoleur, donc j'espère
que ça va arriver.
Ca viendra par la force des choses.
Déjà, je pensais pas prendre
autant de plaisir
à couper du bois, etc.,
donc ça, c'est déjà coché.
Je m'en sors pas trop mal.
-On est motivés.
La sécheresse, ça motive.
Tu veux que je te...
-On est motivés par la nécessité.
Si dans les années qui arrivent,
on arrive à être indépendants
en légumes,
indépendants en fruits,
c'est tout bénéf', et on aura réussi
ce qu'on veut faire.
-Le couple qui installe une cuve,
je comprends la démarche.
La crise de l'eau,
j'ai dû être le seul homme politique
qui a essayé de sonner l'alerte
au niveau de la présidentielle.
Il y avait déjà des gens,
sur le plan associatif,
mais c'est une prise de conscience,
il y a 5-6 ans.
On comprend que c'est vital
et que ça tourne à la catastrophe.
Donc je commence ma campagne
avec ça.
Résultat : walou, zéro.
C'est-à-dire que ça n'a pas pris.
Personne n'a rebondit,
n'a voulu entrer dans la discussion.
-En 2012, mon premier vote
pour une présidentielle,
ça a été pour Mélenchon.
Une sorte de vision.
Il a compris que c'était
ce qu'il fallait porter comme idées,
qu'il fallait allier l'écologie,
le social, l'anticapitalisme.
Il y a une sorte de...
C'est ce que j'aime,
dans le programme.
Il y a une volonté
de réduire ma dépendance
à un système.
Pour être plus en accord
les idées que je défends
en tant que militant,
c'est important
d'être en adéquation.
Il y a aussi cette idée-là
que j'ai un enfant.
Quand on s'est posé la question
de faire un enfant,
c'était : dans quelle monde
notre fille grandira ?
-Avoir la responsabilité
d'un autre être humain,
ça remet en question ses priorités,
ça peut aussi accentuer
certaines angoisses.
-C'est rouge, ce sera joli.
A Mulhouse, on avait
un petit jardin de 80 mètres carrés.
Là, il fait 3000.
Donc...
Ca change, on a
notre petite forêt perso.
-Il y a aussi le fait qu'il y a
plus de sécurité à la campagne.
Il y a un côté de moi
qui me dit que l'effondrement
peut peut-être arriver un jour,
et à ce moment-là,
il faudra être protégé.
-Mais je leur dis :
"Je comprends ce que vous faites,
"mais attention, la solution,
c'est pas chacun pour soi,
"chacun sa cuve de flotte,
"chacun son générateur
d'électricité."
La solution, elle est collective.
C'est une autre gestion de l'eau,
économe, prudente, méthodique.
Et c'est pas en régulant l'eau
au moment de se brosser les dents
qu'on va régler
le problème de l'eau.
C'est en expropriant
les compagnies privées
qui exploitent l'eau,
en organisant des coopératives,
c'est en ayant
une action sociale.
-Agir pour la cause,
agir pour soi : le dilemme
de toute personne engagée.
Et si les deux
étaient compatibles ?
-Je suis un fils de militant.
Je suis un enfant
de SOS Racisme.
Mes parents s'y s'ont rencontrés.
J'ai grandi avec mon père
qui me racontait
sa vie de militant, qui m'a appris
ce que c'était que d'être de gauche,
ce que c'était,
les inégalités, de lutter
contre les inégalités.
Donc j'ai grandi dans la politique.
Là, j'arrive à un stade
où il va falloir
que je recommence à militer
dans pas très longtemps
parce que quand t'es loin
des choses qui se passent,
t'es tout de suite largué,
et moi, ça commence à me manquer
un petit peu aussi.
-Un matin, on se lève,
tout est devenu mécanique.
Ca y est, la routine nous a piégé.
-Bonjour, il faut aller
voter dimanche.
C'est le second tour
des législatives.
On était en tête,
donc on peut gagner.
-Sauf que sur notre route,
une rencontre va nous réveiller,
du genre femme brillante
et expérimentée.
Ses passions : le changement
et l'environnement.
-Donc là, on est devant
au premier tour,
mais de pas grand-chose.
Je suis Claire Lejeune,
j'ai 28 ans
et je suis en thèse
de sciences politiques.
Et à côté,
je suis militante
depuis un certain nombre d'années,
maintenant.
Bonjour.
-Vous allez faire baisser
les taxes d'essence à 60 % ?
-On va bloquer les prix.
-Ca, c'est bien.
-C'est une des mesures-clés.
-Bon courage, en tout cas.
-Merci.
Au moment de la montée
en puissance du mouvement
climat jeune en France,
j'étais co-secrétaire fédérale
des jeunes écologistes.
Musique dynamique
-Des jeunes femmes
comme Claire Lejeune
sont les personnes qui,
dans la génération qui arrive,
vont être les organisatrices
de la planification
dans notre pays.
-C'est une belle prise.
-Elle ? Ah oui.
Et elle existe
en plusieurs exemplaires,
pas identiques,
mais des jeunes gens qui ont
cette puissance de caractère,
de volonté d'engagement
et clarté intellectuelle.
Je dors tranquille,
la relève est vraiment assurée.
-Des jeunes gens engagés.
Avec Claire, Jean-Luc a trouvé
une camarade solide
pour faire sa révolution citoyenne.
-J'ai voulu faire la campagne
de Mélenchon parce que c'était
à mon sens la seule campagne
qui se donnait vraiment comme but
de gagner, rien d'autre.
Quand on regarde le bilan,
on a recréé une forme
d'unité à gauche,
sur al base d'un score
qui était quand même de 22 %,
ce qui est immense.
C'est-à-dire qu'on s'est remis
du hollandisme.
On a mis à distance
cette gauche qui en fait
avait complètement intégré
qu'il y a
le système tel qu'il est,
et on va essayer de le rendre
un petit peu moins brutal.
C'est pas l'enjeu de notre époque.
L'enjeu pour ma génération,
c'est de changer le système.
-Sauf que sortir du capitalisme,
c'est comme sortir de son canapé
quand on y est bien installé :
on voit pas tout de suite l'intérêt,
et même quand on est de gauche.
-Le coeur de la doctrine,
comme le professait le socialisme,
c'était le développement
des forces productives.
C'était une vision productiviste.
J'avais dit : "Avec le capitalisme,
c'est une pour les pauvres,
"une Mercedes pour les riches.
Avec nous, Mercedes pour tous !"
Quelle bêtise !
Oui, c'est le productivisme, ça :
"Allez, en avant !"
L'avoir fait l'être.
De tout ça, j'ai compris
que l'écologie politique
offrait un angle,
un balcon
complètement différent
pour regarder le monde
qui me permettait
de refaire une synthèse
entre mes objectifs sociaux.
Pour moi, l'écologie,
c'est que social.
-Remettre en question
tout son modèle de vie
pour se lancer
dans la grande aventure
de la planification écologique,
c'est parfois un peu risqué,
surtout quand on a besoin
d'embarquer un maximum de gens
pour que ça marche.
-Notre candidate est là,
jeune comme vous !
-Le moment où cette politisation
s'est transformée
en engagement, ça faisait 3-4 ans
que je faisais que travailler,
et j'avais une perte de sens.
On passe nos vies dans les bouquins.
C'est extrêmement instructif
sur le plan personnel,
mais je suis là aussi
parce que je veux
que les choses changent, etc.
On raconte un autre monde possible,
et le but, c'est de faire
que ça devienne possible
dans la tête des gens,
et à partir de là,
ça se traduit dans les urnes,
et ça se traduit, on l'espère,
dans une prise de pouvoir.
-Marier la théorie et la pratique.
Après des années à militer
sur le terrain,
auprès des migrants,
des sans-logements, Claire est là.
Tu personnalises tes...
-Ah, comme ça, ça montre qu'on est
vraiment venus en vrai de vrai.
-Pas le choix.
Claire et sa génération
doivent composer avec l'héritage
des Trente Glorieuses.
-Bonsoir, monsieur.
-NUPES ?
Comme d'hab', NUPES, ça passera pas.
-Ici, ça peut passer,
one est en tête au premier tour.
Voilà, ça peut passer.
-Ca peut.
Même vous, vous êtes pas sûre.
-Oui, mais si on faisait
que des choses pour lesquelles
on est sûrs,
on ferait pas grand-chose.
-On est au moins une dizaine ici,
on est tous en galère.
Personne vient nous voir.
-Ouais.
-Donc on vote pas.
Ce soir, tu vas être chez toi.
-Oui.
C'est ça qui est pas normal.
-Moi, quoi qu'il en soit,
avec tous mes amis,
on va être sur le banc.
-C'est ce qu'on essaie de changer.
-Avant les élections,
vous pouvez le changer très fort.
-Comment ?
-Il y a beaucoup
d'appartements vides.
-Mais nous, sans pouvoir politique,
on n'a pas le pouvoir là-dessus.
-On le connaît,
le pouvoir politique.
On est délaissés.
-Je le comprends.
-Vous ne le vivez pas,
vous ne pouvez pas le comprendre.
-Claire et sa génération
doivent accepter la dure réalité :
les nouveaux partenaires
paient souvent les pots cassés
de nos histoires passées.
-J'ai 27 ans
et je me sens pas responsable
des politiques de droite
qui ont été menées dans le pays
que la question du mal-logement
et la question de la précarité.
On essaie de changer tout ça.
Après, je comprends sa colère
et j'ai pas d'arguments
à lui opposer,
juste peut-être l'écouter,
essayer de montrer
qu'on comprend et qu'on essaie
de faire de notre mieux.
Merci beaucoup.
Bonsoir.
C'est bon, OK.
Ca va ?
-Un insoumis,
en général, on peut le distinguer
de tous les autres
parce qu'il vous pourrit
le repas du dimanche.
Il va amener le sujet politique
et provoquer le bazar.
-La période délicate
des désaccords,
impossible d'y échapper.
Comment gérer ça
au mieux ?
On peut s'asseoir autour d'une table
et discuter...
-A table,
on éteint toujours
les téléphones.
-Mon père, Pascal,
est cadre
dans l'entreprise du coin,
et il y a ma mère, Yolène,
qui est fonctionnaire,
qui travaille dans un lycée.
-Bon appétit, les jeunes.
-Bah oui, bon ap'.
-Et les moins jeunes.
Les moins jeunes.
-Maman va faire la grève, jeudi.
-Si je peux, oui.
-Première grève de sa vie.
-Ouais.
-Attends, c'est important.
Mon père, lui, politiquement,
il se situe à droite,
mais on discute quand même bien
avec lui de plus en plus.
Ma mère avait pour habitude
de voter comme mon père,
et depuis 2022, elle s'est mise
à voter à gauche,
et un peu plus selon
ses propres idées à elle.
Nous, on va à Paris, les jeunes.
Tu y vas ?
-Tu vas à Paris, toi ?
-Avec les jeunes insoumis,
l'Union Pirate.
-Attention, soyez prudents.
-Bah oui.
C'est tranquille.
-Le problème, c'est que des fois,
ça dégénère, tu y es pour rien
et tu te prends des coups.
C'est ça qui est un peu...
-T'es jamais allé dans une manif !
Elle en a fait 10 fois plus que toi.
-C'est vrai.
-Exprimer son point de vue,
se confronter aux autres,
et si le conflit permettait aussi
d'avancer ?
-Mélenchon est un très bon orateur,
un des meilleurs.
Quand on l'écoute...
-Sans déconner, t'as voté Sarko
toute ta vie...
-Oui, j'ai voté Sarko.
Oui, mais je trouve que...
-T'as aussi voté Macron.
Il avait prévenu qu'il voulait
la retraite à 65 ans.
-C'est vrai.
-Ca arrive de faire des erreurs.
-Oui bah voilà.
-Ca fait beaucoup d'erreurs.
-Chaque homme politique
raconte des bêtises.
-Je sais pas si
c'est l'effet Juliette
ou des enfants de manière
générale... Là, on est trois.
Non mais accepte ce que tu...
-J'ai pas changé, je...
Je trouve que les écarts
sont de plus en plus importants,
et c'est pas normal.
-Bah voilà, donc...
-Ils étaient pas aussi importants
il y a 10 ans, je vous assure.
-Ca implique quoi, d'écouter
la jeunesse, aujourd'hui ?
-D'accepter de se remettre en cause.
-Non mais de toute façon,
t'es de gauche.
Rires
-Non, je suis pas sûr
d'être de gauche.
J'en sais rien.
Je sais pas.
Mais...
Mais en politique, d'abord,
j'y connais pas grand-chose.
Je suis désolé, mais c'est pas
parce que Juliette est LFIste.
Pas du tout.
-Je me suis pas dit :
"Les jeunes vont m'apprendre
des trucs."
J'ai appris comment moi,
je m'étais enfermé.
-Alors peut-être que si...
-Je pense, indirectement.
-Peut-être, mais...
-Il faut pas nier l'évidence.
-La vie démentait absolument
tout ce à quoi on avait cru.
On est donc tellement trompés !
-T'as pas envie de l'avouer.
-Peut-être, peut-être.
-Mais si vous acceptez pas
de vous faire secouer...
Je sais pas.
-Vous aimez qu'on vous secoue ?
-Pas trop, hein.
Mais oui, j'aime bien aller
au contact
de ce que je comprends pas,
ou de ce qui trouble
mes certitudes, oui.
Oui, oui, oui.
Oui !
Mais mollo, pas de l'extérieur.
C'est moi qui décide.
-Je comprends pas
ce qui t'as pris.
-Tu entendais pas
ce qu'on te disait.
-C'est possible, mais à l'époque,
j'avais peut-être
un problème d'oreille.
-D'ouïe, oui, sans doute.
-J'avais peut-être
des bouchons de cire. De ton côté,
je pense que tu as mûri aussi.
-Bien sûr.
-Tu réfléchis peut-être
un peu plus avant de parler,
et moi aussi,
peut-être, probablement.
-Faire preuve de maturité.
Qui doit montrer l'exemple ?
Les parents ou les enfants ?
Les représentants ou les citoyens ?
Dans les familles politiques
comme dans les vraies familles,
les rôles sont parfois inversés.
-Je suis raisonné : parfois,
je trouve que Mélenchon,
il dit des grosses conneries
et il est un peu con.
Après, il n'y a pas que lui.
Quatennens qui tape sa femme,
c'est cool, mais ça me fait chier.
-C'est cool
ou ça te fait chier, du coup ?
-C'est chiant. Tout ce qui touche
à la politique, ça m'emmerde.
J'ai eu l'espoir un jour.
Je l'ai plus. C'est parti vite.
-L'affaire Quatennens
et le soutien de Jean-Luc Mélenchon
au député condamné
pour violences conjugales.
Comment ne pas être déçu,
quand on croit à de meilleurs
rapports hommes-femmes ?
Comment ne pas douter
de ses propres choix politiques
quand on est féministe et qu'on vote
pour la France Insoumise ?
-En tant
que responsable politique de gauche,
on s'est dit : "Comment c'est
possible que ça ait pu arriver,
"d'en arriver là ?"
Du coup, on assume mais...
-Après, c'est quand même...
C'est dans une vie privée.
C'est du privé. Je sais pas
si on a le droit de...
Je sais pas.
-Tu frappes pas ta femme,
c'est tout.
-Oui.
-Oui, ça, c'est sûr.
-Au moment de l'affaire,
quand j'ai lu sa lettre,
je me souviens avoir été
très triste pour être honnête.
Et puis par derrière,
j'ai pensé aussi à la victime,
du coup, sa femme, et donc voilà.
C'est une histoire
qui a fait vachement parler.
Tant mieux si c'est
pour parler des violences
que subissent les femmes.
Jean-Luc Mélenchon a fait
des tweets qui...
qui étaient pas
forcément nécessaires,
je pense qui étaient
un peu maladroits,
et qui auraient pu
être bien meilleurs.
Musique contemplative
...
-Bien meilleurs,
c'est sûr, mais...
-Vous pensez ça, vraiment ?
-Il faut apprendre de tout.
Si vous communiquez sans arriver
au but que vous vous êtes fixé,
il faut faire mieux.
Donc clairement,
ma manière de m'exprimer
dans cette circonstance
pouvait pas s'entendre
comme je voulais.
J'ai commencé par vous dire
qu'elle a raison, c'est maladroit.
Pas parce que c'est faux,
mais ça correspond pas
à ce que je veux dire...
-Qu'est-ce que vous vouliez dire,
alors ?
-Je comprends qu'on me dise :
"Il y a une exemplarité !"
OK, on en parle.
Mais on en parle
comme des sujets
où on essaye d'avoir tous
une attitude rationnelle,
et une attitude
qui va essayer de...
de penser au futur,
d'être conforme à nos principes.
Vous voudriez
que je révise ma position !
-Pourquoi pas ?
-Ben non ! Non, non !
J'aurais mieux fait de me taire.
-Bon, on essaye de...
-Non, j'ai plus envie.
-Juste la conclusion !
-Non, y en a pas.
-Monsieur.
Juste ce que vous vouliez dire...
-Démerdez-vous.
Faites mieux si vous pouvez.
-Tant pis.
On se relèvera, hein.
-Comment poursuivre la relation
quand la confiance est abîmée ?
On peut se consoler
avec des choses simples
comme un bon vieux principe :
on n'est jamais mieux servi
que par soi-même.
-Tu m'adoubes.
-Oui, c'est ça.
-Merci.
Super. Reine du monde.
Acclamations
-"Faites mieux" :
comment interpréter
les mots de Jean-Luc Mélenchon ?
"Faites mieux",
est-ce une invitation ?
-Ca disait :
"J'ai fini ma tâche.
"Faites mieux.
C'est la vôtre."
-Déjà, ça m'incite encore plus
à donner de moi-même
et à faire mieux, justement.
-"Faites mieux", ça sonne
un peu comme un défi, non ?
-"Faites mieux" :
"Faites gagner nos idées,
"qu'on arrive au pouvoir
et qu'on change les choses".
-Vous y croyez, vous,
un SMIC à 1600 ?
-On essaie de faire en sorte
que les gens y croient.
-Ouais... Ca,
c'est un peu plus compliqué.
-"Faites mieux",
c'est peut-être un conseil.
-Toi aussi, fais mieux,
Mélenchon !
Tu contrôles pas ce que tu dis.
T'es tout le temps en colère.
Tu la contrôles mal.
C'est culotté,
venant d'une certaine génération,
de dire : "Faites mieux".
Tout le comportement des jeunes,
c'est des résultats
de la génération précédente.
Donc on fait mieux,
on essaie de faire avec ce qu'on a.
-PLUS CHAUD,
PLUS CHAUD QUE LE CLIMAT !
-Comment ne pas tomber
dans le piège de nos schémas ?
-Je m'adresse pas à un jeune
comme à un jeune :
"T'es un petit jeune,
je te caresse la tête,
"je vais t'expliquer la vie".
Je fais pas ça.
-Comment fuir nos contradictions ?
-Je suis en paternaliste
absolument incorrigible.
-Comment se libérer de celui
qui nous a ouvert le chemin,
quand la loyauté
et le respect s'en mêlent ?
-Aujourd'hui,
sans Jean-Luc Mélenchon,
la France Insoumise
ne serait pas avec 75 députés
à l'Assemblée nationale.
-Il n'y a ni grand amour,
ni homme politique providentiel,
au final.
Il y a des histoires simples...
-On devrait manger à sa faim.
-...et de grandes aventures.
-Mon rêve, c'est qu'on arrive
à refaire collectif, déjà.
-TOUS ENSEMBLE, TOUS ENSEMBLE,
GREVE GENERALE !
-Et peut-être qu'en essayant
de sortir de nos rôles...
-Faire mieux, en quelque sorte,
y compris en tant qu'individu,
il faut qu'on s'améliore
et être conscient
de ces mécanismes patriarcaux.
-Peut-être qu'en sonnant
la fin d'une culture,
celle du père,
peut-être qu'en arrêtant
d'attendre qu'on nous passe
le flambeau,
on réussira un jour
à faire mieux.
-Mon chef politique idéal,
ce serait une femme écolo.
-Des coeurs, plein de coeurs.
Je peux faire des coeurs partout.
Dalia rit.
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA